let's go to trade trade with china trade
with different countries what is your
view on trade how different would your
trade philosophies be than what we have
today
my trade philosophy is that people have
the right to trade their goods and
services
with other people regardless of where
they are
and that when you throw tariffs in there
that's basically a hidden tax and people
pay more
uh you know let's go to bangladesh that
makes a lot of close
uh if if we put tariffs
now
poor people in this country
have to pay more for their close and
what we have is we have a government
that
puts all these regulations in place to
increase prices and then the government
says oh i guess we have to hand out
welfare well maybe if they got rid of
some of these regulations
we would have cheaper goods and services
and people would be able to buy things
at a reasonable or cheap cost so how
would you how would your relationship
with china be today how would you how
different would you treat china i hope i
hope i would have a very good uh
relationship with china as with other
countries what does that mean i mean
that's that's well that means yeah the
the example that i like to give is
uh japan
which is
you know 1941 world war ii horrible
they bombed us
and i point out you know we buy so many
hondas and toyotas now
uh they're not gonna bomb us now because
you tend to not bomb your best customer
so
when goods cross borders soldiers don't
have to so if you have a good trading
partner then why would you
um you know why would there be a problem
because you can help each other who do
you see right now as enemy enemy estate
number one like in america today so
you become president tomorrow who is
some countries that you'd be very
careful doing business with because
their motives may not align with our
motives
well but you have to look at the
leaders versus the people
so friends in saudi arabia years ago
president bush was like oh saudi you
know they're our friends well yeah bush
was friends with the king and and you
know the the the aristocratic people in
saudi arabia
meanwhile the other people are getting
ready for 9 11. so
if we can trade freely and people see
that it's an advantage and that they're
being helped by us
then
we would have a better relationship but
again
it's not a matter of
this ruler versus this ruler it's people
freely trading goods and
which kind of goes to
we talk about foreign oh but that's not
how things are you're saying people so
you so in order for you to
your philosophy to exist everybody in
the world would need to believe in what
you believe in it's not going to happen
you're saying for people to trade freely
with each other well i mean it doesn't
matter to me i shouldn't say it doesn't
matter to me it would be nice if china
could freely trade with switzerland but
you know that's their business all i'm
worried about is americans being able to
trade but in that case if we're freely
trading with china but anything
we we can they can export anything they
want here without any trades or tariffs
but the stuff we export there would we
then also have to not have a tariff on
that end or could they do whatever they
want in that case
when they end up doing that we end up
with more money in our pockets uh if if
they want to punish their people there's
nothing we can do about that what i want
to do is not punish our people i want
our people to be able to get the best
prices they can i think that's naive is
it is it i think in one thing there it's
more short term versus long term is it a
good thing in the short term but
something that could hurt in the long
term
how would it hurt people in the long
term i think if you're if you're if you
have if you have export of goods and
we're now decreasing so you're flooding
the market with international products
which is good for the consumer it's
cheap but in the long term that consumer
needs a job and if we're exporting that
and you don't have tariffs or a way to
protect that what are we doing to
protect the workers in in our country
though well you know politicians let me
give you an example paul and if you
don't mind i need to get please do that
yeah please can you do me a favor and
pull up uh
um
i'm sorry go for it i'll text you go
ahead so um
uh
politicians talk about unforeseen
consequences and that's so frustrating
because
you know like san francisco saying we're
going to prosecute
uh
only 900 or 950 whatever dollars and
above oh we didn't see this coming i
mean no you should have seen it coming
so let's take cars
uh we protected detroit
and what the what the government did
was they said don't worry we'll prop you
up we'll make sure that you know people
pay tariffs and
and so they got lazy and if you look at
what the unions were doing which was
just so frustrating the unions would say
oh well you hired us to put one screw in
over there not you know three screws
over here so we're not going to do it
and so car companies were unable to
innovate and so
now you're still going to this you're
still going to the dealership well i
want the power windows but not the power
door locks and meanwhile japan over
there
which is really competing
they're the ones saying oh guess what
we're going to give you all that free so
basically we're propping up an industry
and and
you know hindering it because we're
we're protecting it from
free market forces
and
if if if the government had not
protected them then maybe they would
have been more competitive and they and
you know it would be like okay union we
don't care what you say you're putting
three screws over there or we're gonna
go get somebody else because we've got
to be able to compete with japan and i
teach in my uh social psychology class
that
competition is good and that's one of
the reasons and and there's a trade-off
but i won't go into the academic stuff
but
the reason that we're walking around
with such awesome phones like yours
right there is basically bill gates and
steve jobs hated each other and they
wanted to outdo each other and each one
came up well i'm going to do this and
then the next one i'm going to do that
and they were fiercely competitive and
were the ones who went out and part of
the reason that technology was able to
um move as fast as it did is that the
government
couldn't keep up
and
regulate it at every level you know when
it comes to cars that's
for you know like 80s 90s kind of low
stan low technology you've got cafe
standards you know mileage uh biden just
put in other mileages so we've got the
government hindering competition by
throwing all these things at them
computers were going so fast they
couldn't even keep up so i think that's
a good example of you're saying that the
government is hindering but if the
government is hindering how then would
not tariffs also just ruin it even more
because i think i think you can either
go away with all of it and have it more
competitive and kind of go about that
route or you can't just take away
certain things if you take away if you
take away tariffs without taking away
unions in that end which is the opposite
end of it right
either they have control or they have no
control so then at that point you're
just hindering more and just crushing it
more oh trust me under jorgensen
administration
the unions would not have the power that
they have now do i think that people
should be able to freely and
collectively get together and bargain
absolutely what i'm completely against
is the special
rules that unions get to where basically
unions can hold companies hostage so if
if if you want to get together and you
you unionize then you say we're going to
demand this and the company says
not we're going to hire you know another
thousand people
goodbye
okay you know
in other words free market union
bargaining yeah
but but but let's go back to that
in regards to china it's very important
stay on china let's stay on china so
it's because it's the country that wants
to take over u.s what do you mean why
you can't say why uh as a candidate it's
what most americans fear the power and
the motive that china has they get up
and talk about america that they want to
break to crush the skull of anybody that
gets in the way and that's their foreign
minister saying that you're saying why
but let me stay on let me let me ask my
question let me ask my question and then
i'll turn it over to you so
if i if i'm a voter whether i'm on the
left or the right i fear certain
countries okay
and uh if i'm uh i'm probably gonna fear
a little bit of iran i'm gonna fear a
little bit of russia i'll probably a lot
more today i'm gonna fear china
and then there's a few other countries
that i would fear right okay to say
yeah it's just give them trade i mean
it's just it's okay let them do trades
with us and as long as they're sending
us the product that's great well what
eventually happens is you eventually
rely on that country where eighty
percent of the chips
are being made there and the value of
cars goes to the roof
and you got china's covet cases are
record-breaking as of today those are
china's covert cases john if you can
show that on the screen and if these
guys get coveted cases i don't know if
you've seen what china just did the
entire nation's been shut down so
they're not working now so i can't get
chips out now so now i have to delay the
value of used cars are about to go up
another 10 percent 20
china doesn't give a [ __ ] about america
china doesn't wake up in the morning
saying well joe jorgensen your
libertarian philosophies are so sweet
we're going to follow it as well and
here's what we're going to follow they
don't care about us and and because of
all these relations we've had with them
over the last 40 years
we have made a country that was not in
the top 10 of gdp now number two is
about to pass up u.s
and they're now realizing the world
revolves around
us us owes them 1.1 trillion dollars of
debt and they got to make those payments
to them if if we're not it's naive to
say that what i do think we're
libertarian would have worked is if a
country's
being founded so your philosophies work
if you go start your own country from
the beginning then i would move to it
but it is so hard to change the
infrastructure of a country like this to
say well let's do this well let's do
that but that also means the way we've
trained all these other powerhouse
countries in the world that we've
empowered they also have to change we're
naive if we think they're going to
change i'll turn it over to you well
there are about four or five questions
packed in there i would still point out
you said that china doesn't care about
us
japan cares about us now
these are two different countries i know
but i keep saying japan japan's not
china i know but my point is is that
japan bombed us earlier they wouldn't
bomb us now because we're buying a lot
you know
what what would they do without us
buying all their toyotas and honda's
it's in their best interest
as i said when goods cross borders
soldiers tend not to but you talked
about chips
part of the reason that we've got so
many chips made in china is because of
the tax structure because of the unions
because of all the problems we've got in
the u.s
that if we could have more of a free
market here then we would have more
chips made here so again i i like to
sometimes quote my running mate in 1996
harry brown he said what the government
does is they break your leg and then
they expect you to be grateful when they
hand you crutches and that's exactly
what we're doing so we we we've got so
many taxes that manufacturing has moved
off but it's in fact uh notice trump
lowered that and some people started
coming back so you know what if we put
that at zero do you think maybe there'd
be chips made here so
yeah that's why we're relying on china
for that oh my god if you go with the
approach of just being passive with
china they will
use and abuse you in capital they will
say i'm so glad a dr joe jorgensen is
president because she is so sweet let's
take advantage of america it's going to
be so awesome for us because look what
russia did here's here's the thing with
russia right how do you think russia
views
biden versus a trump love hate whatever
you want to call trump or biden
russia or the world didn't do anything
under trump's administration okay
you didn't have any afghanistan issues
you had palestine and israel getting
along 25 years first time you didn't
have any of the stuff that was going on
with russia everybody was pretty chill
saying you know what maybe we don't need
to do anything then all of a sudden a
leader like biden gets in nice man seems
like a very nice man i don't know his
motives and all that other stuff but
when i look at him at face value i'm
like okay very nice what happens boom
taliban opportunity boom russia
opportunity ukraine boom everybody's
like opportunity opportunity uh look i i
want to sit there and say
these things make sense
but there's some real legitimate
oppositions america has today
that we have to know how to manage them
okay
again going back to this
joe today
china shut down today
most of our air conditionings comes from
there most of the equipment we get from
there yeah again
we should be making that here but
because of the tax structure because of
the unions because of many other things
we're not and how about we solve that
problem so we can start bringing
manufacturing this brings me back to
this brings me back to
why you ought to consider running for
congress or senate instead of president
this brings me back to why don't you do
a you know working from the bottom
grassroots movement yeah grassroots
movements let's get some more senate
you're at the bitcoin conference why
don't you go inspire a ton of these guys
to go want to go be congressman and
congresswoman and mayors and governors
and senators i just did that yesterday i
talked with somebody who said he was
interested in libertarian and the way he
was talking i asked him well have you
considered running for office actually i
think i've asked two or three people
that but the guy i talked with yesterday
said you know i have been thinking about
that maybe mayor and i said you should
do that so and and we do need more
libertarians at the state and local
levels and our campaign one of our um
goals of our campaign
was to help people running for state and
local so for instance uh probably more
so than any other presidential campaign
what we would do is we would take the
data real time
give it to people who were running for
state and local offices
and uh because in the past many many
different campaigns have promised to
give the information
and they would get them to them like a
year later after the election or not get
it to them at all but we were probably
the best in libertarian party history
for getting that information
to those people so they would have data
they could use so that they could try to
win their offices and we recently had a
libertarian voted into a state rep place
and we do have a couple of prominent
libertarians at the local level and i
think that that is very important
because so many people have never heard
libertarians or were the you know wild
crazy people with the horns and they can
see that we've got very good ideas that
work
and
the people who have run the the
jeff hewitt jim tourney they've been
doing a great job
and
people started saying you know what this
this actually does work you know how
about we do cut taxes how about we do
let people uh make their choice now you
gotta agree with cutting taxes right you
can't that's not the point though of
course i am a capitalist of course i
agree with cutting taxes but for me it's
the all-in package it's not just one
area of cutting tax i can't even get in
with the drugs part okay fine let's just
say if i go oh we just you the reason i
said that is because when i said cutting
taxes you kind of sighed and i thought
well that's common ground now you can
agree on i'm i'm of course i'm there but
here's what i'm thinking about i'm down
so consider me
from the angle i'm processing i can't
run for office i'm not born here if i
was born here i'd have a different
conversation but i can't so i can't
create that kind of change right myself
but but i'm talking more from your
standpoint of where you are
why isn't this message
that is somewhat a common sense not not
trait not a few departs i have a hard
time with some of the parts of it
because you can never you can never
underestimate the power of an enemy that
wants to take you down never if you do
that you are so naive you don't belong
in office you can never underestimate
that and quite frankly i don't want to
have a leader that will underestimate
the enemy because they'll scare the crap
out of me for four years and i want that
person out of office as quickly as
possible i don't want that but i want to
go to another thing can i just say
something really quickly and then
and and the reason i was saying you know
can we move on because maybe this is an
agreed to disagree and there are so many
other topics i'd love to cover if you
enjoyed this short clip click over here
to watch another short clip and if you
want to watch the entire episode the
entire podcast click here
[Music]